now here's where it gets real real scary
hbs
hsbc says customers who refuse to wear a
face mask
will have their accounts withdrawn the
lender reiterated the face masks are
mandatory in all branches
unless legally exempt warning customers
that non-compliance could result in
accounts being closed
now that is where things are getting
worrisome now look look
i i got no problem wearing a mask i
really don't care i don't know people
really don't like it they want to defy
it i get it
some people really are medically exempt
but the issue is
not so much about you know but they
should wear a mask and it's an issue of
when you threaten someone's access to
the economy in general when we're
already a point where like 99
of all currency is digital and not even
physical
that people would lose their right to
bank that
that cancel culture why do we not have
national banks what's going on why do we
have private banks all over the place
it's crazy
i mean there's problems national banks
too well at least the government can
control them
and that's us we have the opportunity to
control them and say no you can't censor
you think american citizens that's us
you think you could petition nancy
pelosi to do something
it's a big problem because we're in a
situation where these private companies
uh we need to protect ourselves we need
to use our government and i'm not a huge
fan of using the government
but in this case we have global private
companies that are threatening our
sovereignty and we need to use our
government
to protect us right but not national
banks probably a regulation
like well good news on this one of the
good things that trump did right uh
just in the past few months was an order
from the office
of the comptroller of the currency which
is an officer didn't know existed
but they uh put out a uh a regulation
against debanking i'm not sure if it's
gone through yet they were doing the
whole notice and comment period
where they were taking in feedback from
the public but it specifically said
uh people have been trying to use banks
for political reasons
to uh to withdraw service from the gun
industry
uh from private prisons and this new
rule essentially says that if you're
going to withdraw service to someone it
must be because of financial risk
so you know because of defaulted loans
or uh or you know
the the normal reasons why you wouldn't
but that's that's
that's good there still is the problem
that there are
attacks that activists do where they use
fraudulent cards to cause massive
chargebacks and massive fraud you know
that's what happened to gab actually
that is a problem yeah well what's next
if you don't bend the knee your bank
account's going to be deleted i mean
it's absolutely ridiculous i already did
it and
that's that's that was my next point
there's a large number of people that
had
their bank accounts taken away because
of their political opinion
and when we look at hsbc they don't have
the best reputation themselves
if you remember at occupy wall street me
and you actually met
hsbc whistleblower we actually talked
about even doing a bigger story with
another news organization about that
that exposed uh we were the we were the
first story that kind of broke it how
hsbc helped
terrorist iran mexican drug cartels
launder money
and that was another huge issue about
this you know a record of this company
that did awful things now lecturing us
about what is right and good for you
i mean it's it's just ridiculous i'm not
going to take their advice
seriously because they don't get to
choose what i do in my own personal life
well look i think i need to change my
bank account
so hsbc in the us and in the uk look if
if there's a physical building
that's privately owned and they say you
have to wear a mask the extent
to what their powers should be is please
leave until you have a mask on that's it
banking needs some kind of protections
look man i i've
uh it's remarkable that i've always been
in favor of
of curtailing map power be it government
or
corporate power so i'm in favor of
regulations i'm in favor of leveraging
government against corporations that are
too big too powerful
especially individuals who would use
that power and access
to manipulate the political sphere
because if we don't deal with that
and perhaps it's too late you know i've
heard this you know in the past decade
or so from the left that it's too late
to actually make a difference because we
are a what what
remember that citibank report you guys
remember this back in like it was during
occupy wall street
they said the u.s the us government is
no longer a democratic republic
or a constitutional republic it is a
plutonomy where the ruling class of
elites and wealthy control everything
and there was a study that showed that
public perception and public opinion had
no
impact at all on legislation none
and that the impact was the opinions of
lobbyists and the wealthy elites
that's what occupy wall street was upset
with
and you know what's interesting i
actually think donald trump
is the evolution of occupy wall street
in many ways don't get me wrong bernie
sanders
was some of it it's like occupy split a
little bit then he went to bernie
interestingly though once bernie sold
out went full on establishment
he retained a lot of those people from
occupy probably because their issues
during occupy was more
i don't know social justice but a lot of
the people who supported trump
were many of them were occupy wall
street uh activists i remember i was at
the deplorable when you know just before
trump was getting inaugurated
and there were people there who saw me
and they're like hey we're big fans and
i was like
wow trump supporters you know big fans
of mine and they're like oh yeah we
were we were a big occupy wall street
activists and i was like
really and they're like oh yeah this is
why trump won in 2016 because he called
out the uh the
plutonomy he killed something he said
there's a class of global elites that
get away with everything and run
everything you don't really have a
democratic republican anymore he's
basically saying the same thing that was
in that report
yeah yeah there's also a lot of occupy
wall street people who are like
burn it all down let's vote for him
let's vote
and uh another thing specifically
connecting occupy wall street and hsbc
there was a huge
backlash against the banks specifically
hsbc for this money laundering
where they ended up paying a 1.9 billion
dollar fine
in 2012 for that horrible action that
they were caught with their panel on the
laundering for drug cartels
uh so and they found their cudgel bro
yeah
so they can get away with the worst
atrocities these big corporations man i
love it
these big corporations disney the
banking the uh the paramilitary group in
in was it xinjiang where the the the
weaker muslims are in concentration
thank you for for helping us produce
this movie and then they can come out
with all their social justice narratives
and statements and everyone just rolls
with it
you know what i think the reality is
though they got their useful idiots
they got their their personalities who
hate trump and and just want to own the
cons and all that stuff
i think most people get it though i
think i think
most people understand there's a problem
with big corporations
unfortunately many of them got wrapped
up in trump derangement syndrome because
the
the the strategy from the you know major
media and these companies works
you just keep screaming black lives
matter is okay and then you you blame
the trump supporters for everything
and when that narrative is just repeated
over and over and over
what ends up happening is you've got
people who only watch mainstream news
and every every version of a trump
supporter they see is the angry loud
spitting disrespectful lunatic
and they don't see a regular person you
know they don't see a a
well chamberlain for instance we just
reference one of his articles suit
wearing lawyer
calm very vanilla they don't see that uh
excuse me
all dressed up for this appearance but
right but like you could you could go to
uh you know i was just i was just out
shopping
and the the lady you know at the store
she's like a trump supporter and she's a
regular low low ladies like you know
serving baked goods
they see the tv they live in big cities
so they don't encounter very many trump
supporters and if they do
those people won't admit it so they
don't realize it and they watch the
cnn and they just rag on trump all day
and night and then they're told all the
riots are good
and that shapes their world view and
they don't realize i think you mentioned
it earlier that the left and the right
populists agree
on a lot more than they disagree on
but it's it's an excellent way to get
away with
slave labor and concentration camps
because all they got to do is put out
their little commercial where they're
like we're for social justice and then
you know put a rainbow flag
and they and that's it no outrage no
media uh you know complaints and it
really does come down to you know where
you stand on the woke stuff where do you
stand on critical race theory or
feminism or so and that's what divides
a lot of people and you know some people
you know theorize that corporation
support woke stuff for precisely this
reason
i don't agree with that i think they
genuinely believe this stuff but uh it's
inconsequential at the end of the day
and uh this is what allows the sort of
uniparty to maintain power
you know you know what i hear what
you're saying and i've just had a
realization i've been wrong this whole
time
the woke stuff is good it's great
ian did you know the federal federal
reserve is run by old white men
well let's burn it down then no no no no
no we need to get the old white men out
and diversify the federal reserve
we need new rules new regulations and we
need hard oversight to make sure that
all of the people who are sitting in
seats of power at the federal reserve
are no longer there anymore because
they're white men down with the
patriarchy down with the patriarchy all
right we're all in agreement everybody
agrees
that uh the banking system is run by old
white men which it is and therefore
we need diversity in the bank no don't
use evil to accomplish your goals
kidding the joke is i i'm curious
because
we didn't mention this the other day
like where is anyone to just be like
screw it okay i'm down with the wokeness
hey look the military industrial complex
is a bunch of white people too
well that's that's like using evil to
accomplish your goals that's
part of the problem with using fascism
to get trump out of office to to use
social media
right it's like you can't you shouldn't
use evil and use
fascism to defeat your enemy because it
doesn't work it's it's it defeats your
enemy but it keeps fascism
yeah it might destroy your enemy but
you're gonna create what you use
the system you use so if you're using
hatred you know you're just gonna
like you know i was thinking about uh
the banking systems and all this stuff
and how really weird it is that it's
just numbers typed in a computer
and then a ledger keeping track of it
and that's it that's all the money
system really is
it's the it's it's powerful elites who
run the banks who decide who has access
to resources
it's essentially what we have now in
this in this centralized banking system
is a way to control absolute power
in a country or countries while
convincing people that they're
you know voting in democratic
institutions and the other way to
control them is of course the tech
giants now that's how you control
communication
and that's why they'll crush all any and
all competition
that's why parlor was just obliterated
if
trump in the middle of the night without
saying a word to anyone
signed up for parlor and then posted
trump is here they would not have been
able to have banned parlor
it would have been too much too many
people would have known it would have
been a major story and it would have
been too much
no i think they would have done i don't
think they really cared i think that
might have even
made them more determined to cross paths
i disagree i think the story would have
been
it would have been too much for the
average person to see that they
annihilated an entire social network
because trump joined it
they got rid of parlor before trump
joined it and they used bs reasons they
you know amazon said we don't believe
you'll be effective in your moderation
what does that even mean how do you
break a contract on what you believe
might happen is it as bad what could
they do that would be worse than letting
hang mike pence trend which is what
twitter did
or the fact now that it's it's starting
to come out the the
capital uh riots was was organized on
facebook
glenn greenwald reported that first and
now facebook's going uh
well actually how do you answer for that
yeah and there's even fbi reports of
supposed war coming to the capitol with
them knowing that there was a major
clash point happening there
that they chose to what looks like
ignore and nothing was really done about
it
at all so that's yet another kind of
thing to really kind of consider here
moving forward
facebook is responsible i mean it's not
surprising
you know if you want to defend facebook
by all means you can go ahead and do it
it's the biggest platform everybody use
it so of course they're gonna use their
organizing tools
the problem i have isn't to blame
facebook because they exist
problem i have is the concerted effort
from silicon valley to crush any
any rivals using fake reasons like
saying parlor
had extremist content and they were
organizing on parlor well as the ceo of
parlor pointed out
we have no organizing system there's no
way to organize events on parlor
facebook has events and groups parlor
doesn't it doesn't make sense
and amazon claimed that they didn't
believe the moderation would work why
because the reality was parlor was
removing the threats and the violence
they were doing exactly as they were
supposed to exactly as their rule stated
and getting rid of illegal content so
amazon had to say
well we don't think future moderation
will be effective because the reality
was current moderation was and that's
how they justify crushing it
and then what happens is you know it you
have these useful idiot sycophants
it's like you guys ever watched that
cartoon recess you ever see that
you remember recess it's about the kids
in the school inside recess and there's
like uh
i can't remember the the old nasty
teacher's name and she was really mean
to the kids
and she had this little hunchback kid
who was like her henchmen who would
always do what she wanted
that's journalism awesome that's
journalism right it's like it's like
igor
they're like hobbling next to the
establishment elites of the corporations
yes hillary tell me what to do democrats
yes you're a bad guy you're a bad guy
tell me that i'm doing a good job
democrats that's the media
yeah the media has really been an engine
of big tech censorship even more than
the tech companies themselves i think
because every time a tech company wasn't
censoring enough
wasn't doing it fast enough or whatever
you'd have this huge media campaign to
start an ad voice because they did that
to youtube with the adpocalypse they did
it to facebook just last summer
because they weren't censoring enough of
donald trump's ads so they've
tech companies have to deal with that
ever-present threat if they don't play
ball the media will start
uh an ad boycott well that's even
according to alexandria ocasio-cortez
with her
statement today that who's saying that
you know social media companies aren't
censoring
enough of speech and she quote wants to
reign
in the media to stop the spread of
disinformation those are her words that
she used af you know today
as of course she was also calling for
the banning of parlor she was also
suggesting putting trump supporters on
lists so they could be quote held
accountable for their actions
and and again when we look at alexandria
ocasio-cortez she's kind of this kind of
thought leader of the left that's very
popular that's always promoted
always pushed but she's pushing for some
of the worst authoritarian draconian
measures
that you could ever imagine and for some
reason no one is even
questioning it or or trying to say hey
this is not because they're scared of
antifa
not look listen you know antifa has
created a culture of
mainstream establishment protection to
where
it's it's it's like i was saying about
these businesses that fall in line and
ban parlor because they're scared
cnn msnbc will defend auntie for why
because they're terrified of them
that's why when you saw that msnbc guy
whatever his name was standing in front
of a building with like 50 foot tall
flames
and he goes it's mostly peaceful why he
who's standing around these people
could you imagine what would happen if
you walked into a crowd of antifa and
black lives matter who were burning down
buildings and said
these violent lunatics are destroying
buildings and setting fire they'd be
like
shut them down they're trying to
obfuscate it when rioters were
rioting and breaking into the cnn
building in atlanta
they're like it was so it was so amazing
to see the perplexing
reporting that was happening when they
were getting attacked
in their own headquarters and and they
were just having the most
difficult time time trying to break down
what was happening here look man this is
the problem that conservatives and trump
supporters have
it is it is the the powerful
establishment elites are dangling keys
in front of the trump supporters
in the direction of political
institutions
and that's what the trump supporters are
looking at meanwhile
upstream where the politics comes from
the culture the left has already taken
over
and they're using that against trump
supporters so
when they when the trump supporters go
to the capitol everyone says that's
you know horrible why would you do that
but when the left goes with pitchforks
to
you know big tack to silicon valley to
the universities and spray paints things
on the walls and starts fires and burns
on whole cities
well that scares everybody into getting
whipped into line i would say
i don't know well it was andrew
breitbart who said politics is
downstream from cult culture
right the question is i mean how do you
change that how do you change the
culture when they have control over the
institutions the education system
hollywood now the big tech companies the
algorithms
the algorithms so i mean the internet
was helping for a while
uh i i was saying you know the the one
uh foothold that conservatives have in
culture
every single meme that millennials use
probably came from 4chan already at one
of these very politically incorrect
places
right but now they're shutting the
internet off as well now reddit is
very far left oh yeah reddit is now not
always not always right it used to be
it used to be free for all yeah and they
purged everything the number one post on
reddit that i saw today was a picture of
charlie kirk
saying that he's a domestic terrorist
everyone upvotes this if you agree he's
a domestic terrorist and it reached
number one on all right and it was
shocking seeing the comments because
there's a lot of trump supporters that
don't like charlie kirk
yeah and he's he's he's more of the
establishment kind of rhino republican
and not even the kind of
outsider that a lot of people expect him
to be what i do like is i'll go on
reddit sometimes
and there will be uh a charlie kirk meme
where they make his face really small
and that's funny though like making fun
of somebody and you're like whatever
it's like okay it's a funny meme his
face shrinks as the more he says
conservative things
but when they say domestic terrorist
when they say threat to our safety
that's the kind of inflammatory rhetoric
that leads to real world violence
i'm not saying they can't say it don't
get me wrong because i believe in free
speech
i'm just saying they shouldn't be going
out claiming that the right is engaging
in violent hate speech
when it's literally what they do the
crazy thing about it is
the dominant like you know the front
page of red at the top of all it's
dominated by like
four like three different ocasio-cortez
profiles
all they do is repost aoc's tweets and
then up vote them straight to the top
right that's what the donald got banned
for
and now here we are with the exact same
problem which shows
the people who ran reddit it's funny
because i used to i used to know them i
used to hang i've been
i used to hang out their offices every
so often a couple times not like a whole
lot
and they used to just be very much you
know what people like they like what
they have what they upload
and then i guess they're in a city and
you had
you know let me let me tell you
something i talked to some very powerful
democratic donors
who were looking at ways to create apps
that would
function like social media platforms and
would would actually be
like campaign tools like the idea at
first this is a long time it was like
2014.
they were like how do we create an app
for the campaign that functions like
reddit
and so i had con meetings with people
and they never really went anywhere
and then to see what's happened now with
the with the astroturfing of a place
like reddit
if you post a conservative opinion or
even a moderate one you're obliterated
you're gone your comment doesn't exist
everything is dominated by the left but
the extremist tribal left
it's not even about this is why that's
why i said earlier it's tribalism it's
not even about economic policy
like think about if i came for and i
said i believe we should have more
progressive tax brackets
they'd be like well you're far right in
what capacity is that
doesn't matter because it's tribalism
has nothing to do with what your
politics are
it has to do with who you align with
that's like the uh the tribalist is like
the
it's like the distant hand of the
control of the culture which is
the rich people it's the money and it
has been for probably
since the beginning of time since the
creation of currency or wealth in
general
used to be gold it was salt and then in
the 70s they turned it into fiat
so now it's just whoever has the most
numbers in their bank account but now
there's this for the last 50 years it's
been such a mind
f screw that like people don't know who
who controls the culture and there's
like this this
this combat conflict at the top and now
there's cryptocurrency
appearing but it's the rich people that
are controlling the culture which then
it heads down and they're using
these tribalist ventures to god forbid
create war but i think maybe like the
great reset and they really want the
united states to fight itself
because it's it's standing in the way of
like a socialist the dictatorship the
problem is where power actually lies in
society has been kind of concealed for a
while people still think that you know
the senate or the house of
representatives is really important
that's really just political theatre
just look at how they behave with the
tech giants right they bring him in for
hearings
every few months and then do absolutely
nothing after the hearings
most power now now lies in the federal
bureaucracy political power anyway
and the rest of the power lies as we've
seen in the tech giants with the banks
with the corporations
i think it's almost like the elections
i've often felt have been pointless
and only after donald trump won did i go
like well
you know maybe voting is it doesn't
matter like wow i can't believe trump
won
but now i still feel very similarly
trump won and so what
no honestly look he won the republicans
were in power they didn't do anything
they didn't give they didn't help trump
at all they just sit on their hands
and i think it's basically what you said
it's it's it's almost like they're
uh you know like queen elizabeth
everybody loves her you know
in the uk but what does she do she is
the head of state but they say her role
is mostly ceremonial
she does have the executive authority
right to like override and make these
yeah but she never theory but she never
does and that's what i feel like we have
now
when you watch that hearing where ted
cruz he's like you're censoring
conservatives and it's like that's right
ted you tell him that yeah afterwards
what are you gonna do
yeah what are you gonna do now again
there are some republicans who have
presented bills to do stuff and then no
one sponsored them they'll get voted on
they don't go anywhere so it's almost
kind of just ceremonial at this point
yep are you guys prequel fans the star
wars prequels
do you remember how in the in the
phantom menace
the phantom menace somehow got politics
right okay because
the entire first half of the movie is
about
the queen of the planet who's just been
invaded trying to get to the republic
senate and make her case
and when she and when she gets there uh
she's asked for
she's they demand more proof of this
so-called invasion
and the chancellor says well he'll have
a committee discuss it right right so
somehow they got american politics right
there that was a perfect allegory
i think what you said about the kind of
corporate elite being in charge is
absolutely true and when we really look
at it it's it's not just a corporate
elite it's a corporate banking
billionaire elite that's absolutely
unaccountable
and commits some of the worst human
atrocities that they they're never held
accountable for whether it's
monsanto bp coca-cola nike they have a
horrendous
record of abuse of civil rights of of
human rights abuses
that deserve to be addressed and yet
they're lecturing us about how we should
live our lives
they're lecturing us about social
justice it's absolutely absurd but
they're becoming more emboldened
with what they could think that they
could get away with with telling us to
do
and i'm and i don't understand how
people are okay with this and totally
forget the history
of union organizers being killed by
cartel members
which a lot of people point directly to
coca-cola for organizing
you see that that meme the left used to
understand this but then they got
distracted by transgender pronouns
yes you see this meme where it's a a a
pig with a monocle and a top hat
and it says buy our product and there's
an antifa guy and he's yelling and then
below it it says buy our product but
product is big and rainbow
and the person takes his mask i was like
ah i guess
i guess that works you know it's amazing
to me how
you have this tribalism on the left
which i believe is really rooted in
not entirely but mostly rooted in hating
conservatives and thinking they're evil
whereas as the saying goes you know the
left thinks conservatives are evil
the conservatives thinks that the left
is misguided
conservatives care about being left
alone
simple policy it's often the arguments
you'll hear from from right-wing
individuals
not entirely the left they do argue for
things like universal healthcare and
stuff
but at least online it's very much
owning the cons
you do have the right version of that
but what i've noticed
is that where do the seats of power lie
on the left and the right
on the right it is not the q and on
people certainly they're influential in
their own right and that's kind of
you know weird but the most prominent
voices and the most powerful and largest
are like conservative
inc you know run of the mill mainstream
look at ben shapiro
he is your typical conservative he is
particularly mainstream
you know in terms of left or right look
at the left though it's ocasio-cortez
12 million followers getting a hundred
thousand concurrent views
not moderate mainstream democrats so the
overton window is shifted to the left
and it's remarkable when i hear the left
say it's shifted right i'm like do you
know anything about the past decade of
politics
trump it's like less war you know what
are you talking about when they said
when
i guess you know what's funny it's
nationalism when you don't want to go
blow up other countries and it's a bad
thing
i guess what about we saw i keep
thinking about the saudi princes like we
talk about the wealthiest elite of the
globe
as the banking system but how do the
princes and the kings of
sod tie into this because they say like
elon's the richest man in the world but
he's not
he's just the richest man on the books
you have the saudi king
uh and the princes that are like
trillionaires you know they own the
country
and all the people in it um and
the united states sold them a bunch of
weapons like trump yeah sold out sold us
out to saudi arabia yeah
that's not trump it's it's it's a
weapons deal
it's the us it's the office of the
president it's authorized it includes
trump
but it's trump it's it's obama it's bush
it's you said all of them when you said
he was like a holdover of occupy wall
street i don't agree i just think he
happened to be rich but he's a sellout
he would have sold us out in a heartbeat
he did no i think
trump was a raging bull that was
stampeding through the ivory tower
and so what the occupy wall street
people were like this is really
interesting because it's split you had
bernie sanders challenging the machine
but then he joined the machine
and then you had donald trump who was
this wealthy billionaire elite who then
started ranting and raving about how he
didn't like it and challenging the
establishment
it's kind of weird how that twist
occurred but i think you had a lot of
people from occupy
who eventually just threw their arms in
the air and said send in the bull
like you know what man what's going to
fix this just have him rob about for a
little bit
yeah i mean what happened so here's my
here's my take on trump i mean he was
you know the raging bully couldn't be
controlled he was genuinely outside this
system
and they couldn't control him but once
he actually got power he just got
kind of completely ruled by the
establishment uh
you know they got all the establishment
republicans got their people in the
administration and nothing really
started
happening until the last year of the
administration thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you